[Music]
you know sometimes the difference is
just whether you think you can or you
think you can't it will Henry Ford quote
if you think you can't or you think you
can't you're right sometimes I mean I
know stuff comes against you I know some
of you have had illness I know some of
you were victims of all kinds of
different abuse and different things
have happened to you
I know you some of you were victims of
racism or sexism or I'm a victim of bald
ISM people discriminate against me
because I don't have hair I actually had
a young guy come up to me this weekend
he said I hope when I'm your age I have
as much energy as you do I almost hit
him that's ageism right there
our bald ISM our energy is amour
something I don't know everybody's got
something though I'll tell you that
there's a lot of reasons why you
shouldn't make it and you can adopt one
of those as your pet this is my little
pet reason meet my little reason my
little pet reason right here hidden he's
sweet he keeps me from winning because I
believe he's I believe him when he
twists purse in my ear my pet recent
doesn't mean I can't win because people
from my background I've never won no one
in my family has ever gone to college no
one in my family has ever had a million
dollars no one in my family is no one
from where I grew up no one that's my
color no one that's my sex no one that
has hair doesn't have hair no one like
me has ever that's your little pet
reason you got your little pet it's a
cute little reason cute little pet
reason you needed you a little reason
why you could be a victim instead of a
victor didn't you you see I think you
gotta set your pet reason free like you
know set it free let it go latch on and
be a parasite on someone else because
it's a lie
oh I understand it's an obstacle I
understand it's a blocker
I understand there's problems out there
but I also understand people just like
you
are winning they're having the best
marriages they're having incredible kids
in spite of their little pet reason
they're getting out of that they're
building wealth they're actually
communicating with their spouse on the
same page with their own spouse about
money what a novel freaking concept I
can't get my husband on board and that's
your little pet reason it's a cute
little pet reason everybody's got a
dadgum excuse me too
I got an excuse I just decided I wasn't
going to find me
I don't know if y'all noticed or not but
I speak with a southern accent that's my
reason because everyone knows that
southern people are all dumb everybody
knows that right
all you Yankees think that too many of
you do stupid stereotypes it's
ridiculous isn't it interesting
everybody's got a little pet reason you
can sit right there and pet your little
reason no pet reason it's cute you have
your reason why you can't win you can
win you can do this stuff you can do
this stuff is it easy awkward no if it
was easy we wouldn't call him winning of
course it's not easy it's just worth it